Olá, muito boa noite a todos. É um
grande prazer estar aqui com vocês. Eu
vou contar uma história que aconteceu
aqui no consultório faz algumas semanas.
Tem um paciente de 54 anos, aquela cara
de quem trabalha que nem um condenado.
Bem, ele senta na cadeira na minha
frente e me diz assim, bem sem jeito.
Doutor, eu tô tomando curcumina faz 3
meses e não mudou absolutamente nada.
Gastei uma nota, meu joelho continua
inflamado, isso não serve para nada. Eu
acordo de manhã parecendo um robô
enferrujado. Aí eu pedi para ele me
mostrar o que que ele tava tomando.
Então ele puxou do bolso uma caixinha.
Eu olhei o rótulo e pensei: "Hum, meu
amigo, você literalmente jogou dinheiro
no lixo." Sabe por quê? Porque ele tava
tomando curcumina de qualquer jeito.
Vagabunda. Dessas que o pessoal só raspa
lá a cúrcuma, né? A o açafrão, pega o pó
e coloca na cápsula.
e tava tomando, sabe quanto? 50 mg por
cápsula. Não tinha nenhuma tecnologia,
não tinha adição de pimenta preta, não
tinha orientação para tomar junto com
gordura saudável. Era como se ele
tivesse bebendo água com corante
amarelo, né? efeito zero. E realmente eu
fico irritado às vezes porque as pessoas
com maior boa intenção procuram um
produto de alta qualidade e a gente tem
essa situação aí de tá o pessoal
vendendo gato por leve na internet ou
até mesmo umas farmácias menos éticas, o
pessoal não está tendo a devida
umbridade de est explicando para as
pessoas diferenças entre os produtos
diferentes, né?
Essa indústria também que não deixa nada
claro, empurra produto que não funciona
para cima de gente que tá sofrendo, que
tá com dor e que passa a não acreditar
mais no produto porque teve uma má
experiência. E esse pessoal precisa de
ajuda de verdade, né? A gente não pode
ficar aceitando que esse pessoal em dor,
uma inflamação importante que às vezes
tem um uma contraindicação de tomar um
antiinflamatório convencional, tem
problema de estômago, problema nos
insins, problema de coração no fígado e
a gente quer oferecer uma coisa de
qualidade, uma coisa natural e aí eles
são passados para trás. Eu fico
realmente muito chateado com isso. Então
hoje eu vou te mostrar porque nove em
cada 10 pessoas que tomam curcumina
estão desperdiçando dinheiro. E mais
importante, eu vou ensinar exatamente
como usar corcumina do jeito certo, com
base em estudos recentes. São de 2024 e
25. Então é coisa bem recente. Então
deixa eu explicar uma coisa que vai
mudar completamente a forma quando que
você enxerga a suplementação.
A gente vive numa época onde todo mundo
fala de cocumina, né? tá bem famosa, é
um dos ativos aí mais estudados, tem
mais de 500 estudos. Então você vai na
academia, alguém tá tomando, você
encontra um vizinho, uma tia, né, ela tá
tomando.
Alguém que tem artrose no joelho tá
tomando também. Só que a maioria das
pessoas não tem a menor ideia do que tá
fazendo, né? Olha que coisa
interessante. Tem mais de 15.000 estudos
científicos. Então nós temos mais de
15.000 estudos no total sobre curcumina.
Então ele é praticamente um dos ativos
mais estudados junto com, né, ômega-3,
vitamina D. Então esse composto amarelo
que vem da cúrcuma, que é aquela raiz
que parece gengibre, mas é amarela, foi
muito muito estudada. Infelizmente nós
não temos aqueles estudos gigantescos
que são muito caros, né, os randomiz
control trials, mas a gente tem muitos
estudos. Então, os cientistas
comprovaram que a curcumina funciona pra
inflamação, para dor aticular, pra
proteção cardiovascular, ajuda a regular
as gorduras do sangue, pra função
cerebral e tem ação também anticâncer.
Então, a cucumina é um agente com muita
ação simultânea.
Então, mas aí vem um problema que é o
elefante na sala que ninguém te conta,
né? A cocomina comum tem apenas 1% de
biodisponibilidade. 1%. Tá? Deixa eu
traduzir isso em português claro. De
cada 100 mg que você engole, só 1 mg vai
chegar na sua corrente sanguínea. Os
outros 99 passam direto pelo seu
intestino, vão embora. Às vezes isso até
aceitável, às vezes isso até desejável.
Digamos que tem intestino irritável.
Hoje mesmo atendi uma criança com
intestino não irritável, mas tinha
inflamação intestinal do tipo
retocolitos sererativa. Aí às vezes você
quer que a cúrcuma, a curcumina tenha
asação local no intestino, você não quer
que seja tão absorvida. Então nesses
casos, faz sentido você usar uma cucuma
assim, mas pra grande maioria dos casos
não. Você quer que seja bem absorvido.
Então quando só 1% dessa cucumina é
absorvida, é um grande problema, né? E
os outros 99 vão passar direto pelo
intestino. Podem ter até ação local no
intestino que é interessante, mas o
resto vai embora no vaso sanitário. Aí
você fica ali achando que tá bafando,
que tá se cuidando. Então é tipo você
comprar um carro, mas só conseguir usar
o retrovisor. Tecnicamente você tem um
carro, mas para que que serve, né? Um
carro que você só consegue usar o
retrovisor.
Agora compara isso com remédio comum de
farmácia. Você pega, por exemplo, o
ibuprofeno,
esse carinha, né, tem biodisponibilidade
de 80 a 90%. Seria um excelente remédio
se não estragasse o seu estômago, seus
rins e o seu fígado, né? Então,
praticamente tudo que você toma do
ibuprofeno vai entrar pro sangue e vai
fazer efeito. De novo, se você tem uma
dor muito intensa, você bateu em algum
lugar, teve uma queda, teve uma
inflamação aguda, não há nenhum problema
de você tomar embuprofeno, de clofenáco,
nimesulíde ou a secclofenáco durante até
uns 5 a 7 dias, mas não há nenhum
problema nisso, tá? Não é um pecado. O
problema é quando você tem que tomar
isso por muito tempo e aí você vai ter
os efeitos colaterais, OK? Então aqui
esse é o ponto principal que a curcumina
não tem esses problemas, pelo contrário,
até protege o rim, ao contrário dos
antiinflamatórios que vão gerar
problemas no rim.
Então a cucumina vagabunda, né, ao
contrário do profofeno que 80% vai
absorver, ela não vai ser absorvida, vai
tudo pra lata do lixo.
Então é um despesío de dinheiro, é uma
desesperança que a pessoa passa a não
acreditar no produto. Aí você me
pergunta: "Mas doutor, se cucomina não
absorve, por que que tem tanto estudo
mostrando que funciona?" E é uma ótima
pergunta. Essa é a questão que separa
quem entende de suplementação de quem só
repete o que ouviu no Instagram, no
Instagram. Então, os estudos que mostram
resultado de verdade, principalmente os
publicados recentemente, ano passado e
esse ano, que foram publicados em
revistas científicas sérias, usam
formulações especiais de curcumina, não
é curcumina pelada, são formulações com
tecnologia para aumentar a absorção, que
quando você aumenta a absorção, aí sim
ela pega, ela vai ser absorvida e vai
ter efeito. Aí você vai ver resultado.
Então, tem um estudo de 2025 publicado
muito interessante. Os pesquisadores
compararam várias formulações diferentes
de curcumina e viram uma coisa
impressionante. Certas, certas
formulações conseguem aumentar a
biodisponibilidade em 20 vezes, outras
em 45 vezes e tem até umas que chegam a
vezes mais absorção. Então você ouviu
direito, 185
vezes. Então é a diferença entre dirigir
um Fusca e pilotar um foguete, né? mesma
substância efeito completamente
diferente. Então, deixa eu te mostrar os
três erros fatais que a maioria das
pessoas comete quando compra a cocumina.
Primeiro erro que é o campeão, o mais
comum, comprar curcumina comum achando
que tá fazendo a coisa certa. Primeiro
que muitas vezes nem é curcumina mesmo,
é cúrcuma ralada, como eu expliquei. Aí
o pessoal tem dificuldade de entender. É
fácil entender, pessoal. Veja bem, café
e cafeína, quando você vai comprar no
supermercado, você compra café. Quando
você vai na farmácia, você compra uma
cafeína. Muitas vezes você compra na
forma de pré-treino, né, para dar aquela
energia com pré-treino. Então, ninguém
confunde cafeína com café. Concorda? Por
que você confundiria cúrcuma com
curcumina? Não confunda. Uma coisa, uma
coisa, outra coisa, outra coisa. Então,
cúrcuma é a planta de onde é extraída a
cucumina. E aí você tem vários produtos
no mercado, vários tipos de suplemento,
alguns sem nenhum tipo de tecnologia de
melhor absorção e nem concentrou ali os
cucuminóides. Cucuminoides é uma
substância que a gente quer com efeito
anti-inflamatório, ok? Então
não confunda. Lembra do café e da
cafeína? Você compra café na
supermercado e compra cafeína na
farmácia. É, seria a mesma coisa com a
cúrcuma. Você compra cúrcuma ou açafrão
da terra ou açafrão da Índia no
supermercado e na farmácia você compra
cucumina. Então, muitas vezes você faz o
quê? Você compra essa curcumina entre
aspas que é um açafrão ralado, achando
que tá fazendo a coisa certa. Você vai
lá, compra na internet ou ver aquela
caixinha bonita, lê lá curcumina 500 mg.
Pensa: "Nossa, que dose maravilhosa, né?
Vou tomar esse 500 mg duas vezes ao dia,
tá top. Vai paraa casa feliz da vida,
né? né, com a sua compra. Só que você
não perguntou a única coisa que importa,
na vez as duas únicas coisas que
importam. Primeiro,
qual que é a padronização desse produto?
Ele tem quantos de cocuminoides? E qual
é a tecnologia de absorção? Se não tem
tecnologia nenhuma, você acabou de
comprar um pó amarelo caro.
Ok? Segundo erro, tomar sem combinação
adequada. Muita gente não sabe, mas a
curcumina precisa de gordura ou de
pimenta preta bioperina para ser
absorvida, porque ela é lipossolúvel,
ok? Então, eu já falei isso em vários
vídeos no meu canal, quem quiser ver tem
acho que tem, deve ter uns 10 vídeos no
canal sobre cocumina. Então, é tipo
vitamina D, precisa de gordura. Se você
tomar em jejum com estômago vazio, vai
diminuir muito a absorção, pode
esquecer. Então já é naturalmente ruim a
absorção. Aí você toma um estômago
vazio, sem gordura, fica pior ainda. Ou
ainda nem coloca uma pimenta preta que
vai ajudar na absorção. E tem gente que
toma com suco de laranja pela manhã
achando que tá bafando. Não tá porque
não tem gordura junto, né? Não tem
bioperina da piperina que é da pimenta
preta, tá jogando dinheiro fora de novo.
Próximo erro, dosagem homeopática.
Quando a gente trabalha com uma cúrcuma
ou curcumina, que não é uma tecnologia
de alta absorção,
50 mg, por exemplo, de cucumina não vai
fazer nenhum efeito. 100 mg também não
vai fazer nenhum efeito. Para ter um
efeito terapêutico de verdade, para você
de fato sentir diferença na dor, na
inflamação e também melhora nos exames
de sangue, você precisa de dose adequada
com formulação adequada.
Não adianta tomar pouquinho de um
produto ruim, você vai continuar sem
resultado e vai sair por aí falando que
comida não serve para nada, não
funciona. Ela funciona. Você é que não
foi informado corretamente sobre o uso.
Agora vou te contar uma coisa que vai
mexer com você. Sabe por a medicina
ortodoxa, a medicina alopata não fala
quase nada de cocumina? Por que que o
médico comum, o médico que você vê aí
aparecendo nos programas muitas vezes
matinais da TV Globo ou horário do
almoço, por que que ele não comenta
muito sobre isso e por que que o médico
em geral não receita isso para você?
Então, deixa eu te dar um dado. A
indústria farmacêutica de
anti-inflamatórios é uma das mais
lucrativas que existe e movimenta vários
bilhões de dólares por ano, né? Então
tem muita gente ganhando dinheiro.
Infelizmente também muitos desses
pacientes estão indo pra fila de
diálise, de hemodiálise. Lógico. De
novo, você usar uma semana um
antiinflamatório, não vai acontecer isso
com você, não ser que seja muito
azarado. Agora fica tomando aí
depofenáco, selecoxibe, buprofenon,
nemesulídia aí durante, sei lá, 4 anos,
vê o que vai acontecer com o seu rim.
Isso se você não tiver uma úlcera no
estômago antes, né? Vê o que que vai
acontecer com o seu fígado, né? né?
Agora imagina se todo mundo de repente
descobrisse que existe uma substância
natural sem patente que faz praticamente
o mesmo efeito para uso prolongado, né?
Tô falando de uso prolongado sem
estragar o seu estômbo, o seu rim. O que
que acontecer com esse mercado
multibilionário aí de antiinflamatórios,
né? Inclusive com venda direta, sem
receita. E olha que interessante, tem
estudos comparando exatamente a focina
com anti-inflamatórios comuns. Então tem
um estudo de 2021 que revisou 15 ensaios
clínicos randomizados e controlados
talos RCTs, randomized control trials,
certo? é os pais dos RCTs. E esse estudo
então pegou a revisão desses 15 ensaios,
o mais alto nível, né, de ciência por
serem RCTs, o padrão ouro da ciência,
comparando curcumina com
antiinflamatórios não esteroidais em
pessoas com artrite de joelho. E sabe
qual que foi o resultado? A curcomina
funcionou tão bem quanto o ibuprofeno e
o celecoxib para reduzir a dor e
melhorar a função articular. Deixa eu
repetir, tão bem quanto e sem estragar
os seus órgãos e pelo contrário, protege
até o rim.
E tem uma diferença também gritante,
zero efeito colateral no estômago, nos
inscado.
Tem um outro estudo também
impressionante, foi publicado 2019,
comparou curcumina com diclofenac.
Diclofenaco, vocês conhecem, né, que é
antiflamatório que todo mundo já tomou
uma vez na vida, que o médico receita
com muita frequência para inflamação.
Então, nesse estudo, 139 pacientes com
osteoartrite foram divididos em dois
grupos. Um grupo tomou cocomina 500 mg
três vezes ao dia. O outro grupo de
clofenaco, 50 mg duas vezes ao dia.
Resultado, 94%
das pessoas do grupo curcumina tiveram
pelo menos 50% de melhora nos sintomas.
No grupo de clofenaco, 97%.
Então, empatou praticamente a mesma
coisa. Mas aqui vem o plot twist.
Significativamente menos pessoas do
grupo Cucumina reportaram efeitos
adversos, ou seja, efeitos colaterais. É
o que eu tava falando agora. E nenhuma,
repito, nenhuma pessoa do grupo cucumina
precisou usar bloqueador de acidez,
bloqueador de próton, né? Os famosos
prazois omepraszol, pantopraszol,
lanzoprasol, exomepraszol. Enquanto
isso, no grupo de culofenáco, um monte
de gente teve que tomar prazol junto.
Você entende o que que significa isso?
Significa que a gente tem uma
alternativa natural, eficaz, comprovado
cientificamente que funciona tão bem
quanto o remédio de farmácia, mas sem
ferrar os seus estômagos, sem ferrar o
seu coração, sem aumentar o risco de
infarto, sem danificar o seu rim e nem
danificar o seu fígado no longo prazo.
Mas o pessoal da Big Farma não quer que
você saiba disso porque não tem patente,
né, e porque não interessa a eles.
qualquer laboratório, né? Pode trabalhar
curcumina com com tanto que seja um
laboratório aí de idôneo, né, que não
vai te vender uma porcaria.
Certo? Agora atenção, porque aqui a
coisa fica técnica, tá? Vou ser um
pouquinho técnico aqui, mas eu vou
explicar de um jeito que você vai
entender tranquilamente como é que
curcumina funciona no seu corpo. Ela age
em dois caminhos principais. Primeiro,
ela inibe uma enzima chamada Cox 2, CO2.
e ela é responsável por produzir
prostaglandinas inflamatórias. Que que é
prostaglandina inflamatória? São os
marcadores, são os mensageiros celulares
que vão levar a informação de uma célula
para outra de que tá acontecendo um
processo de dano no seu organismo, tá?
Então é exatamente o mesmo mecanismo dos
anti-inflamatórios convencionais, o
bloqueio das prostaglandinas
inflamatórias através da inibição da
enzima COC 2. A diferença é que a
cocomina faz isso de uma maneira
natural, modula a expressão genética
dessa enzima, enquanto anti-inflamatório
sintético bloqueia na porrada essa
situação. Então, pode parecer a mesma
coisa, mas a abordagem funcional, aquela
visão mais ampla do organismo, mostra
que regular a expressão gênica é muito
mais elegante e seguro do que
simplesmente bloquear na força bruta uma
via enzimática.
Segundo caminho, curcumina inibe o NFK
beta, tá? Esse é o maestro da orquestra
inflamatória. Então, quando você tem uma
inflamação crônica, esse carinha aí tá
lá ativado direto, mandando o seu corpo
produzir citocinas inflamatórias sem
parar. Então, a cucumina vai lá e acalma
isso daí. É como se ela fosse lá e
falasse pro maestro: "Cara, relaxa,
relaxa, não precisa tocar fortíssimo o
tempo todo, não". E tem mais, muito
mais. A curcumina, ela atravessa a
barreira hematoencefálica ou
hematolicórica. E você sabe o que que
isso significa? Significa que para que
ela consiga chegar no seu cérebro, ela
precisa passar por essa barreira. Então,
ela consegue atravessar essa barreira. E
a maioria dos compostos não consegue
fazer isso. O seu cérebro, por natureza,
e graças a Deus, é super protegido, tem
uma barreira bem seletiva que não deixa
qualquer coisa entrar. Mas graças a Deus
também a curcomina passa e lá no cérebro
ela faz coisa sensacional. Ela protege
os neurônios, reduz a neuroinflamação,
aumenta um fator de crescimento
neuronal, um fator que ajuda os
neurônios se recuperarem o fator
neurotrópico derivado do cérebro, é o
brain derived neurotropic factor, BDNF,
que é essencial para manter sua memória
e cognição em dia. Então, tem estudos
mostrando que a cucumina pode ajudar a
prevenir o Alzheimer e outras doenças
neurodegenerativas. A gente usa também
na prática clínica no protocolo recode
para tratamento do défic cognitivo.
Lógico, a gente não vai usar só
cucumina, a gente vai usar várias outras
coisas, mas ela faz parte do protocolo
recode de reversão do dé cognitivo.
Então, no fígado, a cucumina ela
potencializa a detoxificação da fase
dois. Ela aumenta a produção de gluta ou
seja, cucumina melhora detox, aumenta
essa enzima fundamental, a gluta que é
um antioxidante mais poderoso que seu
corpo produz.
Então é literalmente como se você desse
um upgrade no sistema de limpeza do seu
organismo. E no sistema do coração
cardiovascular, ela reduz a oxidação do
LDL, como eu tava falando, ela modula
essa questão das lipoproteínas.
Então o que realmente nós queremos, que
faz sentido, não é dar porrada no LDL.
DDL tem função do organismo. Ele pega o
colesterol, que é matériapra, ele leva
do fígado até os tecidos, ok?
Então não é que o LDL é bandido, ele tem
função, tá? Então esse LDL é como se
fosse um navio que vai levando o
colesterol do fígado até os tecidos que
vão usar, principalmente a suprarrenal
que vai produzir os hormônios
esteroides, tá? Você vai precisar de
progesterona, vai precisar de cortisol,
vai precisar de endosterona, vai
precisar de testosterona, vai precisar
de vários estradiol, estriol, tudo isso
vem da pregnenolona, que é fabricado
através do colesterol que vem pelo LDL.
O LDL não é bandido. O problema do LDL é
quando ele oxida
ou glica e quando ele oxida, ele
atravessa a parede da artéria e inflama
dentro da parede da artéria. Aí a
artéria vai ficando grossa, vai ficando
calcificada até um belo de que rompe o
ateroma e entope a artéria. Então nós
queremos o quê? LDL grande, fofinho,
parece uma bola de praia, esse não oxida
e nós queremos evitar o LDL bolinha de
good, aquele duro e condensado, tá?
Então esse duro e condensado ele oxida.
Então a cucumina vai atuar reduzindo a
oxidação desse LDL, né, que é esse o
processo que inicia toda a aterosclerose
que vai dar problema na féria. Então não
é o LDL em geral, é o LDL oxidado, que é
o pequeno e denso que oxida.
A cucumina, ela protege contra oxidação
e além disso, ela melhora a função do
endotélio, que é essa parede da artéria,
aquela camadinha interna dos seus vasos
sanguíneos que precisa est funcionando
bem pra pressão ficar normal e
circulação funcional direito. Bem, agora
chegou a hora de falar do que realmente
importa. Biodisponibilidade.
Esse é o divisor de águas. Então tem
basicamente quatro tecnologias
principais que realmente funcionam.
Então tem basicamente quatro tecnologias
principais que realmente funcionam para
biodisponibilidade, ou seja, que vai ter
disponibilidade do produto no seu
sangue, na sua corrente sanguínea.
Primeiro, piperina, que eu já comentei
agora aqui, é o composto ativo da
pimenta preta. Então, a piperina inibe
enzimas que degradam cucumina no fígado
e no intestino. Então, com a piperina
você consegue aumentar a absorção de
curcumina em 20 vezes. 20 vezes, tá? Só
que tem um porém aí. Talvez seja aqui a
pergunta da Maria de Lourdes, tá? Vou
aproveitar que tá na minha cara aqui, ó.
E impressionante é que a médica
gastrologista me disse que a cucumina é
prejudicial para minha gastrite. Talvez
ela tenha falado isso, Maria de Lutes.
Por quê? Porque pessoas que têm
intestino sensível ou sim intestino
irritável ou gastrite, a piperina que
aumenta a absorção da curcumina pode
irritar o seu estômago. Talvez seja isso
que ela tenha falado, tá? Então não é
para todo mundo essa combinação de
piperina com curcumina. Então qual é a
segunda tecnologia que a gente pode
usar? Então, fosfolipídios, que é a base
da formação Meriva. Meriva, além de ser
um carro aqui no Brasil, é uma marca de
um produto muito bom nos Estados Unidos.
É uma é uma curcumina de alta absorção.
Então, você pega a curcumina, encapsula
ela numa bolinha de fosfolipídio, né, um
tipo de gordura, tipo uma gordura
especial. Então isso aumenta a absorção
em aproximadamente 29 vezes e é bem mais
gentil com o intestino, tá? Então, se
você que tem gastrite com intestino
irritável, é interessante utilizar essa
fórmula. Terceira forma de você aumentar
absorção, nanopartículas. Então, já
falei bioperina, né? Ou pimenta preta,
piperina, já falei do fósfolipídio,
terceiro, nanopartículas. Então você
transforma curcumina em partículas bem
pequenininhas, em partículas minúsculas,
tamanho nano, né, nanotecnologia.
E aí a absorção aumenta bastante. Então,
algumas formulações conseguem 185 vezes
mais biodisponibilidade
para essa tecnologia aí. Quarta
tecnologia. fitossomos, que é parecido
com fófolipídeos,
mas usa uma tecnologia específica que
liga a cucumina com fosfatid colina, que
é extraída da soja, de uma forma
particular, que aumenta a absorção em 45
vezes e permite que você use doses
menores com efeito potente. Então essa
tecnologia que eu vou apresentar para
vocês aqui como a principal que eu
gosto, porque você não precisa tomar
megados dose e também não vai custar o
olho da cara. Porque a outra tecnologia,
eu acabei de falar do aquela que eu
falei com vocês que tem o como se diz,
as microbolinhas,
essa daí ela é uma tecnologia puxada no
preço, tá? Essas nanopartículas aí.
Então essa é um meio do caminho, tá? tem
uma absorção muito boa, mas não vai
custar o teu fígado, o teu rim, tá?
Então você pode usar uma dose moderada
desses fitossomas com absorção excelente
que vai fazer um trabalho muito bem
feito. Então
quando eu escutei de um seguidor que
decidiu que queria ter a melhor cucumina
possível na loja de suplementos, então
ela me perguntou: "Qual você recomenda?"
Eu falei: "Tem que ser fitossomo, tá?
Por quê? Porque você não vai vender um
produto com preço muito elevado e também
não pode ser uma cocumina vagabunda, né?
Então tem que ser coisa séria. Então o
produto que ela escolheu para colocar na
loja é o CCUFlex.
É uma das marcas que eu vou apresentar
para vocês. Você tem toda a liberdade de
escolher entre várias marcas, mas o
Cocuflex eu acho um produto muito
interessante. Não é o mais barato do
mercado, mas tá longe de ser o mais
caro, né? E é o que eu gosto de usar
pessoalmente, é o que eu recomendo para
boa parte dos meus pacientes quando eles
me perguntam qual marca deveria comprar.
Então vou apresentar aqui para vocês já
o produto. Esse aqui é o Corcoflex, tá
bom? Que é da Biobalance, uma marca
bastante idônea. Aí tem outras também,
tá? Por exemplo, tem a Curcumitec
da Nutrilibrium, que tem essa tecnologia
dos fosfolipídeos Meriva
também. é um é um fabricante nacional do
mercado brasileiro
e tem capas de 500 mg. Tem também o
curcumim fitosom da Essential Nutrition,
também é um produto interessante que tem
a tecnologia Meriva
e tem também 500 mg por unidade. E tem a
cucumina long vida da Vitafor, que
também tem uma tecnologia de partículas
menores.
Beleza? Mas essa aqui, a Cocuflex, é a
marca que eu mais recomendo. Olha só que
interessante, um estudo bem recente, de
maio de 2025, testou várias formulações
diferentes de cucumina em humanos,
incluindo a formulação com piperina e
formulação nova sol
que usa essa tecnologia micelar. Então,
o que que eles descobriram?
Mesmo usando formulações ditas como de
alta biodisponibilidade,
os níveis plasmáticos de cucumina não
conjugada, que é a forma realmente
ativa, ficaram baixos. Então, a maioria
ficou abaixo de 2 nanomolar. Então, a
nova Sol conseguiu níveis melhores entre
6 e 38 nanomolares nos primeiros 30
minutos, depois caiu rapidamente. Então,
esses níveis ainda são 100 vezes menores
do que a concentração usada em estudo de
laboratório para mostrar efeito
biológico. Então, o que que significa
isso? que talvez os efeitos benéficos da
cucumina não venham só da molécula
absorvida intacta, pode vir também dos
metabólitos dela, dos produtos de
degradação e principalmente do efeito
dela direto no intestino. Então, porque
a maior parte da cucumina fica no
intestino mesmo e não é absorvida.
E lá ela faz um trabalho sensacional.
fala modula a microbiota, reduz
inflamação intestinal, protege a parede
do intestino. Então, mesmo com baixa
absorção sistêmica, ela tem um efeito
poderoso. Mas é óbvio que com formulação
de alta biodisponibilidade você consegue
somar os dois, o efeito local no
intestino e efeito sistêmico no corpo
todo. Agora eu vou dar um protocolo
prático, aquele que eu uso no
consultório como paciente de verdade.
Primeira coisa, você precisa de
curcumina com tecnologia de
biodisponibilidade.
Então, já falei isso várias vezes e vou
falar de novo.
comum não adianta. Segundo, dose
terapêutica
com fitossoma, que é o caso do corpo
flex que eu mostrei aqui. Deixa eu
mostrar de novo.
A dose eficaz fica entre 200 e 500 mg de
complexo por dia. Então, algumas pessoas
precisam mais, outras menos.
Então, vai depender do grau de
inflamação. Terceiro, timing, toma
sempre com refeição que tenha gordura,
almoço ou jantar. Se tomar café da manhã
gordo com ovo e abacate, né, que eu
recomendo gorduras saudáveis, obviamente
pode ser de manhã também, mas tem que
ter gordura junto. Quarto, duração não
adianta milagre em três dias. Cuccumina
não é paracetamol, ela vai agir na causa
da inflamação, não só no sintoma. Então
você precisa de pelo menos 21 a 30 dias
para começar a ver resultado
consistente,
de 20 a 30 dias. Então, em alguns casos
mais crônicos, tipo artriteatoide,
processo autoimune, pode levar de 60 a
90 dias para ter o efeito completo, mas
quando tem esse efeito é durador e
seguro. Quinto ponto, combinações
inteligentes. Combina vai bem com3, que
também é antiflamatório, vai bem com
bosué serrata, funciona bem com vitamina
D, que modula o sistema imune, funciona
bem com magnésio que relaxa os músculos
e reduz a dor. E olha, interessante, tem
situações que você pode usar megados
supervisionados de cocumina por tempo
limitado. Por exemplo, pós-operatória de
cirurgia ortopédica tem estudos
mostrando que usar dose alta de cocumina
nos primeiros 15 dias após a cirurgia
reduz drasticamente inflamação e dor e
acelera a recuperação. Outra situação,
exacerbação aguda de doença autoimune.
Você faz um curso de alta dose por 10
dias, depois volta pra dose de
manutenção. Mas isso tem que ser
supervisionado, porque dose muito alta
pode interagir com alguns medicamentos.
Então, deixa eu dar alguns exemplos de
condições onde comumina brilha.
Osteoartrite,
comprovado em vários estudos, reduz a
dor, melhora a função articular tão bem
quanto o antiinflamatório. Artrite
reumatoide melhora marcadores
inflamatórios, reduz rigidez matinal,
diminui a demarticular e nacina
metabólica melhora a resistência
insulínica, ou seja, baixa o açúcar do
sangue, reduz os triglicerídios,
aumenta então essa situação de saúde das
gorduras do sangue. Então, ajuda também
a controlar o açúcar do sangue. Doença
cardiovascular,
reduz a proteína serrativa, protege o
aidé da oxidação, melhora a função
endotelial na esteatose hepática, ajuda
a regenerar o fígado gorduroso, melhora
enzimas do fígado, pode ser utilizado
síndrome pós- Covid, reduz inflamação
residual, melhora a fadiga, acelera a
recuperação e no declínio incognitivo,
como eu comentei anteriormente, pode
proteger os neurônios, reduzir a
neuroinflamação e melhorar a memória.
equival uma informação valiosa que pouca
a gente sabe, cucumina potencializa a
quimioterapia. Então tem estudos
mostrando que ela aumenta a
sensibilidade de células cancerígenas a
vários quimioterapos,
mas ao mesmo tempo protege as células
normais. Então, em protocolos
oncológicos integrativos, aquela visão
mais ampla do tratamento câncer, a
cucumina ela entra como advogante. Mas
atenção, isso tem que ser feito com
acompanamento médico, porque o timing
importa. Tem momentos que você usa junto
e tem momentos que você pausa antes da
química. Agora, relação custo benefício.
Fazer uma conta de padeiro aqui. Um mês
de culofenác
duas vezes ao dia, sai uns R$ 20. É
baratinho. Só que você vai precisar
deoprasol junto para proteger o
estômago. Mais R$ 20, R$ 40 por mês. Só
que no longo prazo você vai ter que
fazer idososcopia para ver se
desenvolveru gastrite ou úlcera. Mais R$
600, R$ 700. Mais do que isso, na
verdade, esse número tá até bem
conservador e tem risco aumentado de
evento cardiovascular com uso crônico de
antiinflamatório não esteroidal, que o
caso de culofenar, tá? Mas isso a gente
nem vai colocar preço, né? Porque a sua
vida que tá em jogo. Então o cucuflex
tem tecnologia de fitossoma,
custa mais caro, né? né? Não vou mentir,
mas você tá investindo em qualidade, em
absorção de verdade, em proteção ao
invés de agressão. Então, se você fizer
conta total, você tá economizando. Na
verdade, não vai destruir o seu
estômago, não vai aumentar o risco de
infarto, vai sobrecarregar rim em fígado
em investimento em saúde e não gasto com
remédio, né? É totalmente diferente, né?
Porque você tá fazendo uma coisa até de
prevenção, prevenção de alzimer,
prevenção de câncer. Então é bem
diferente tomar o antiinflamatório que é
só para tirar dor. E aqui entre nós, se
você dividir o custo pro dia de uso, não
vai dar um cafezinho de padaria. Então
vou deixar o link do Cocuflex na
descrição do vídeo novamente. Você pode
comprar onde você quiser. Tô
simplesmente facilitando tua vida. E
antes que algum chato venha encher a
paciência, pessoal, ninguém tá falando
aqui, você pode comprar onde você
quiser, tá? Tô facilitando a vida de
vocês. E eu consegui um cupom de
desconto com 10% de desconto para vocês
comprarem durante a live, tá? E até o
dia de amanhã. Então, quem tiver
acompanhando a live agora e adquirir até
amanhã de manhã cedo, vai ter esse
desconto
e você pode comprar qualquer marca de
qualquer site que você quiser, tá? Tem
1000 opções por aí. Eu só tô dando uma
orientação para vocês, porque as
perguntas, as pessoas estão sempre
perguntando qual que eu confio, qual que
eu recomendo. Tô aqui dando para vocês
essa informação, tá? E esse é um produto
que particularmente eu gosto de utilizar
e dou também paraa minha família e pros
pacientes. OK?
E outra coisa, pessoal, teste, não fica
só na teoria, pega seus exames atuais,
principalmente se você tem marcadores
aumentados de inflamação, proteína
reativa aumentada, VHS aumentado,
ferretina alta, sem ser por excesso de
ferro. Pronto, tá aí esse QRcode que tá
aparecendo na tela aí, beleza? É o mesmo
Qcode do link, tá bom? Quem quiser
utilizar o celular, pode usar esse
QRcode aí.
H, cupom de desconto. Esse aqui que eu
apresentei para vocês, ó. Esse o cupom
de desconto, tá? 10% de desconto, tá?
Nos comentários, mas eu vou colocar o
link também no primeiro comentário do
vídeo publicado. Vocês têm aí um período
de algumas horas com esse desconto aí de
10%, é um produto de alta qualidade que
eu uso para mim e para minha família. Eu
recomendo muito. Tem outras marcas que
vocês se quiserem ver as outras marcas,
eu falei de novo umas duas vezes durante
o vídeo, é só voltar o vídeo, tá? Então
eu agradeço muito a participação de
vocês, agradeço muito que vocês tenham
participado dessa live com perguntas
interessantes, inteligentes e a gente se
vê em uma outra ocasião, tá? Muito
obrigado aí pela gentileza de vocês, o
carinho e até a próxima. Um beijo no
coração.